>>Student: How do we know there are
tiny things in a drop of pond water,
we can use a microscope
to view the pond water.
Imagine you could shrink yourself
and walk into a tiny cell,
what is it like inside a cell,
it's a fantastic journey.
>>Teacher: Fascinating, very close.
Thank you so much.
>>Student: It feels
like you're playing
when you're actually learning.
>>Student: Like sometimes,
you could like play a game
and not even know that
you're learning.
>>Student: You're actually
having fun and you realize it,
and then you realize that you're
learning while you're doing it.
>>Teacher: I have to ask that
question, what hat are the kids going
to wear in this mission
that they're going to be on?
And that's part of the
curriculum design process.
I think most teachers do
curriculum design with, "Okay,
what do they need to learn?"
But at Quest, it's "What
do they need to learn,
how are we going to engage them?
And what role are the kids
going to be stepping into
and what story are the kids
going to be stepping into?"
So it's all a part of
creating this narrative.
>>HTTP--
>>Dot colon slash, slash.
That's exactly what's
in front of the website.
>>Teacher: Can I see?
>>Yeah, take it--
>>Teacher: Are you sure
that's what you see?
>>Yeah, HTTP.
>>That's the slide.
>>Teacher: That's really weird,
I totally thought your specimen
number was going to be a plant cell.
>>Wow.
>>That is ODO.
>>The light switch is bent.
>>D-E, that second letter's an E.
>>An E?
>>Teacher: Greetings, TWTW students.
I'm Doctor Smalls.
I work for Shrinkly Labs.
I am honored to say, you
are invited to compete
in the 2013 Shrinkly Labs
cell city design competition.
>>The "Need To Know" is created
by this cast of characters.
There's a teeny little
doctor, named Doctor Smalls,
and he has shrunken himself and put
himself inside of the body of one
of his patients, because
he was trying to find
out what this mystery disease was.
And in shrinking himself, he lost
all of his medical vocabulary
and he sends my students
a communique.
So the "Need To Know" has helped get
me out of this body, I'm trapped,
and help cure my patient.
So it's actually like
completely ridiculous
and the kids know it's a game.
But it's so fun for them to
become a part of this narrative
that they do get right in and they
do get involved and start figuring
out the clues of, "Well,
where is Doctor Smalls now?
Well, we know he's in this hollow
space," and they start learning
about the body from basically these
clues of his location in the body.
So they know that it's all made up
and they know it's all just
play, but it's fun for them.
It's much more fun than just, you
know, PowerPoint after PowerPoint,
"And now we're going to learn
about the respiratory
system, boys and girls."
>>Student: I think we play
games at Quest to learn
because it helps us incorporate
learning into having fun.
>>Student: You could learn
from a game and be like, "Oh,
that was so fun," and
then like read like a book
and be like, "Oh, that was fun..."
>>Teacher: It leads some
kids to get sidetracked.
"Well, you know, this isn't real," or
"I don't care about Doctor Smalls."
But for ninety-nine percent of the
kids, it's like, they're totally in.